On the 16th is when I left England. That
same day I learned that thousands of
Muslims took over London's Trafalgar
Square, probably not pronouncing it
right, to mark their communal breaking
of Ramadan fast, okay? And a dramatic
spectacle, of course, followed
including, uh, you know, thousands of
bodies sprawled all over the street in
prostration as Quran verses blared out
and Allahu Akbar screamed and so forth.
And of course, the mayor was there,
Sadiq Khan, and for some reason or
other, rather than behave like most of
their countrymen, that is to say, as
doormats,
a number of Christians, British
Christians, took umbrage at this. They
dared complain. Here's one quote, for
example, by Nick Timothy, Shadow
Secretary of State for Justice and
Shadow Lord Chancellor. He said, in
reference to this Muslim takeover and
spectacle of prostrations and prayers,
he said, quote, "Too many are too polite
to say this, but mass ritual prayer in
public places is is an act of
domination. The adhan, this is when a
Muslim goes and, uh, proclaims prayers,
the call to prayer, real loud. The
adhan, which declares there is no god
but Allah and Muhammad is his messenger,
is, when called in a public place, a
declaration of domination. Perform these
rituals in mosques if you wish, but they
are not welcome in our public places and
shared institutions. And given their
explicit repudiation of Christianity,
they certainly do not belong in our
churches and cathedrals. The domination
of public places is straight from the
Islamic playbook." Wow. Now, that's a
mouthful, and good for you, Timothy,
because everything he said just so
happens to be correct. Absolutely. I
mean, let's look at some of what he just
said, okay?
Um, first of all, yeah, what does the
adhan declare? Think about it. All these
thousands of Muslims get together,
congregate, in public place, Britain,
London,
and they start yelling, "There is no god
but Allah and Muhammad is his
messenger."
So, what does that mean to the rest of
the people in England who are Christians
by background, at least, heritage, and
some, of course, maybe by faith. So, you
have this alien host that has been
invited to come, and they've been given
all the rights, and they've been
promoted to believe in their religion,
of course, as we were talking. And now
they've gone and taken over London, of
course, Londonistan, where they are
loudly proclaiming a truth to them that
makes you, the Brits, infidels, the
hated enemy, okay? And that truth again,
which the adhan declares, is that it's
the shahada, the number one, um,
principle of becoming a Muslim, saying
that there is no god but Allah, which
means the Judeo-Christian god is all
false, and Muhammad is his messenger,
which means, again, you are wrong
because you don't follow the words of
Muhammad. Therefore, you are also false,
okay? And to think that these, as
Timothy [snorts] was saying, as he's
pointing out, it's one thing to do these
in in an actual mosque, but they're
often times invited into churches, and
they say these words. So, you see what I
was telling you when I was Let's go back
to what I was talking about, you know,
it's one thing to tell a Muslim, or any
faith, or any person of any faith or no
faith that you have this right. Yeah,
I'm not going to coerce you. You can be
an atheist, you can be a Muslim, you can
be whatever you want. I'm not going to
fight with you, and I think you should
have equal civic civil rights as a
citizen. That's one thing. It's another
thing to basically advocate or promote
these beliefs. And so, when a church
invites Muslims to come in, and they
start, you know, hollering and
screaming, "There is no god but Allah
and Muhammad is his messenger," they are
implicitly telling you, "We're right,
you're wrong." And you're sitting there
allowing them in your holy place, your
temple, your sacred worship site for
your god to say that. Do you think that
makes them like you, by the way? Do you
think they look at you and, "Wow, he
you've appeased me. Let me reciprocate."
Or do you think they have nothing but
contempt for you when you do that?
Because it just validates exactly what
they believe, which is you're just You
are a doormat, and we're turning you
into our prayer mat. Bring
back the
Bring back
and the righteous